oh
i'd like to welcome you again uh it's
it's great to see so many people
interested in
free markets and
and liberty
it's winning the battle of ideas that
that's really important
and if you sort of
those that were fortunate to listen to
charles murray last night you could see
that his his ideas that you know we're
not going to change this through
uh trying to just elect the right people
we're going to change it by changing the
culture
i'd like to that this panel is on the
k-12 education system
and you can't pay people more
than the value of what they produce
if i'm walmart i can't pay you ten
dollars an hour if you make eight
dollars an hour worth of stuff
so
any of you that run your own business
how many have run their own business
okay well there you go you know that
right you don't you don't get to lose
money on every unit and make it up in
volume do you
right
so
how do we solve the problem of poverty
well there's only one way to solve the
problem of poverty and that's to make
people more productive
and what we want to think about what
that major component of of making people
more productive is what gary becker
called human capital it's it's investing
in your education whether that be a
school or whether it be training or
whatever it is
but we're focused on that sort of major
one that we talk about which is uh
education
um and let me just to make a little
point here
see this thing you know
i could take a video of you guys
and i could email it to somebody in
london
and now you're going to tell me i can't
teach a fourth grader to read in the
city of detroit
and when was the last time you heard
anyone say do you want to move to
detroit because i want to send my kids
to detroit public schools
or chicago public schools or baltimore
public schools or philadelphia public
schools in fact if i told you your
children or your grandchildren were
going to trenton public schools the next
year
you probably never been to trenton you
don't know anything about their school
system but you're going to go well i
don't know about that
which tells you that it's not a detroit
school system problem it's not a
baltimore school system problem it's a
systematic problem
so each of these panelists are going to
provide an insight into how this system
works
and why it doesn't work nearly as well
as the system that makes iphones which
is the market system
um and and lisa lisa snell is going to
talk about the relationship between uh
k-12 funding how much the money goes
there and the output what are the
outcomes uh terry moe is going to talk
about the politics of this system why
it's so hard uh to make changes and
richard vetter is going to discuss the
effects of government funding on higher
education
so i'd like to begin with introducing
lisa
lisa is the director of education and
welfare at the reason foundation a
non-profit think tank and fancy free
mines and free markets i love that
express free mines and free markets you
know i use it all the time they should
have a bumper sticker
she is frequent
okay
i need to put one on my pickup um
you know i'm missing bow hunting season
right now for this too if you are those
that saw the the talk last night
snell has frequently testified before
the california state legislature and
numerous other state legislatures and
government agencies
she's authored policy studies on school
finance and weighted student funding
universal preschool school violence
charter schools and child advocacy
centers she's a frequent contributor to
reason magazine school reform news and
privatization watch her writings also
appeared in the wall street journal usa
today san francisco chronicle orange
county register l.a times and numerous
other publications
she's also on the advisory she's an
advisory board member to the national
quality improvement center for the
children's bureau he's on the charter
school accreditation team for the
american academy for liberal education
and serves as a board member for the
california virtual academy i'd like you
to welcome lisa snell
thank you all so much
so
we're going to talk about
what relationship does the amount of
money that we spend on education have
to how
our students and i'm going to focus on
the united states in particular perform
so let's just start
with the robert f kennedy community
schools
it's built on the old ambassador hotel
site in los angeles and
it still has the um
what would you call it notoriety of
being the most expensive high school in
the united states at 578 million
and
some of the things that
578 million bought was
state of the art cooking centers like
the food network
theaters sound booths a fabulous faculty
lounge with chandeliers and velvet
cushions that is
3 000 square feet for the faculty lounge
um
and here's an example of the theater
high school theater
so
you know people talk a lot about
if schools are clean if we have nice
buildings so this is an extreme example
of that
and
there are five schools i believe that
share
the robert f kennedy community school
center in los angeles
unified los angeles high school of the
arts
in california we have something called
the academic performance index and it's
an aggregation of all test scores for
all grades in a school so that would be
science and math and algebra and reading
whatever
it's our state tests although the
governor has just signed a bill in
california actually that we're not going
to use that anymore and we're taking a
basically a two-year hiatus with no data
from testing in california to implement
the common core so we're going to have
some gaps when we try to do this
analysis
but as you can see
these schools from their scores in 2012
to 2013
after spending 578 million
the los angeles high school of the arts
lost 27 points the school for visual
arts and humanities lost five points
the ambassador school of global
education lost 12.
one school which is the only elementary
school
gained 18 points and
one thing that's true about student
achievement is it's easier to improve
performance in elementary school than in
middle school and high school the longer
kids stay in school
the more difficult it becomes and
seemingly the worse things get
so let's look at the big picture and if
you don't know andrew coulson at the
cato institute
he wrote the seminal book on free
markets in education called free markets
a history of free markets in education
and i would encourage you all to check
that book out because it really is
historically
shows how we got where we are and
obviously i'm not going to go into that
today but i would recommend andrew's
book
to learn everything about markets and
education historically but we can see
that in 1970 the lifetime cost to put a
single student through school was fifty
seven thousand dollars by twenty ten in
constant twenty thirteen dollars that
was a hundred and sixty four thousand
dollars to put one student through a
lifetime of school
we can see that
total cost has gone way up and then at
the bottom there you see
long-term trends for 17 year olds in
reading math and science and that line
looks a little bit flat right we haven't
made a lot of gains since the 1970s and
that is the big picture we spend a lot
more on
education in the united states for k-12
we get
very little to show for it
similarly if you look at how much the
federal government has spent on
education
you can see that
from the 1970s that line goes way up the
federal government spends a lot more
money than they used to on education and
similarly you can see that student
outcomes are still flat
and in addition to the so this is scores
on the nation's report card we like to
call it the national assessment of
education progress
it um is valid in the sense that it
compares to a lot of international tests
it's a way to benchmark all the
different state tests in terms of rigor
and scores on that are flat if you look
at other things like graduation rates
sat scores
many many different indicators you find
also a similar flat line despite the
fact that we've made a lot of
investments
in education
if you look at the united states
compared to other developed countries in
the oecd's rankings you will see that we
spend a lot of money compared to
everyone else on kids for their lifetime
in school
and one of the interesting things that
the oec did recently is they did a study
of scores on the pisa which is one of
the
international tests that rank countries
on reading and math and other scores and
they found that countries that spend
more than us dollars a hundred thousand
per student from the age of six to
fifteen
so we fall at the top of that
um
they have no difference in improvement
in their scores on international tests
than similar countries that spend half
of that
so estonia hungary poland they there's
no statistically different scoring for
those countries
and switzerland is i mean new zealand
sorry
which scores very high actually has a
lower than average amount per student
that they spend so this is not to say
that one country is better than another
that's a whole different story we could
spend a long time on how we score
internationally and generally it's right
in the middle and not very good for the
amount of money that we spend but
the point of this is
and this is what all of the different
points of evidence show
is that there's no relationship between
spending the amount of money that you
spend and the kinds of student outcomes
that you get and eric kaneshak is the
king of this point and he's written many
many studies
and he has a book called school houses
courthouses and state house houses
solving the school funding policy and i
would also recommend eric's book if you
wanted to really get into the
nitty-gritty of why
school finance doesn't work but i'm just
going to summarize his whole book in 30
seconds
in
1966 it started with the coleman report
which was one of the largest and most
comprehensive with the huge sample size
of studies that looked at the
relationship between resources and
student outcomes
and
basically that study which was very
controversial at the time and kind of
rocked the world showed that there was
no relationship between spending and
outcomes and other factors like
socioeconomic status home life parents
made a much bigger difference than
investments in schools
hanashek who summarized many many
studies says the majority of the studies
have found that the differences in
either the absolute spending level or
spending increases bear little or no
consistent relationship to differences
in student achievement
and there's been studies that look a lot
at a lot of very specific
outputs right now in the united states
we're at about fifteen to one
teacher-student ratios
and if you look at like higher education
if you look at staffing at all levels we
have way more staff members than we have
students and teachers and administrators
and every level of public school workers
has grown
and not at an equal ratio to enrollment
increases
so we have way way more staff and when
we look at low teacher student ratios
doesn't make a difference what about
small class sizes if we just have like
in california we've had a huge mandate
for years for class size reduction
rand and many other reputable outputs
have done large-scale studies and it
doesn't make a difference if you have a
small class size to student performance
one of the things that happened in
california is
because it was a completely inflexible
mandate in kindergarten through third
grade you suddenly needed a lot more
teachers and so the quality of the
teachers was not taken into account when
they were assigned to schools you had
classes taking place in you know janitor
halls and kids in crowded conditions
because you couldn't if you were out of
school and you had one more student over
the 17 class size you'd have to have two
classes instead of having one class with
18 students literally it was a mandate
there was no flexibility for the
principal or the school district to
arrange their resources in ways that
made sense and so then you had a
shortage of
both classroom space and highly
qualified teachers and so consequently
it backfired and you had low outcomes
and that was really the story in
california
teachers salaries have no relationship
so many of these input kind of variables
really have no relationship
there's been studies that look at
different states that spend different
levels and when the nea or different
groups that are stakeholders do their
rankings one of the things is they
always focus on is oh you know
california is 49th they're 50th in
spending and of course depending on
which what kinds of funding you take
into account and which people's numbers
it's all over the map
in general we're right in the middle
here in california for state spending if
you actually look at all the dollars but
that's kind of besides the point what
the nape which is again the nation's
report card shows is that there's no
relationship in spending from one state
to another and high performance
so
low spending states might perform well
and high spending states might perform
well and a lot of states perform poorly
so
there's just it's all over the map and
the spending is not what's making the
difference and then finally in eric's
book court remedies there's been a huge
number of lawsuits in the united states
that go to court on behalf of public
school students and they argue that what
the state is spending is inadequate
that these kids are disadvantaged they
deserve more resources and so there's
been cases in places like new jersey and
abbott school districts which is one of
the most famous ones where they now
spend close to thirty thousand dollars
per kid where they've mandated that you
have to spend more money and generally
so in eric's book they do a long-term
study that of four of these states that
have had
these court remedies for the longest
time and guess what these states that
had 27 000 per kid they're spending st
their outcomes look very similar to the
what they look like in the 1990s before
the court remedies so these court
remedies also have not made a huge
amount of difference
so
now i want to kind of switch gears and i
want to look at what happens when money
follows the child if kids
are actually
have purchasing power are part of the
market
what are indicators that that would be a
better way to go than having a single
payer a single provider monopoly system
that you know doesn't pay attention to
prices and has no incentive to change
behavior we've established right that
spending and achievement is not related
and i'm actually going to talk briefly
about the market and then i'm going to
talk quickly about some original
research that we've been doing in a
study that we're going to be releasing
this month at reason so
school choice has been winning over the
last few years and it may seem like it's
at the margins but the 2000s has have
been a huge positive growth for school
choice programs
there's 48 private school choice
programs in the united states that
include both school vouchers and tax
credits where kids can take money to
private schools of their parents choice
now there are difference in quality of
these programs some of them are highly
regulated but the fact is in general
they've been growing and there's way
more kids where they get to choose their
school than there was in the last 30
years we're at an all-time high
we're at about 260 000 kids which seems
like nothing
that chews schools on a private school
voucher program but that's a huge amount
of growth
in millions of dollars and then if we
turn to the studies
we see that gold standard studies show
that school choice works so when you
hear the obama administration talking
about canceling the dc voucher program
the empirical evidence
although statistically small shows that
those kids do better and they certainly
do work do no worse and they do so for a
lot less money so
the empirical evidence when it's random
assignment has only found positive
effects in a very few cases they've
found no effects but they've never found
a negative effect from using a market
system and that's across academic
outcomes for the school choice
participants for the public schools that
are subject to competition for the
taxpayers for things like racial
segregation
for civic values there's no negative
effect from having market competition
and kids use vouchers or tax credits to
go to school
in addition to school choice from
vouchers and tax credits which would be
farther along the market driven system
we have charter schools and this is
where we've really seen the most growth
in the education market there's now 2.5
million kids this is they haven't
released the new figures but that's what
they're predicting that it's at
so five percent of the public school
population in america is going to
charter schools now charter schools are
regulated but they have a government
contract that
theoretically says they have to perform
fiscally and academically in order to
maintain their school
so that's somewhat of an improvement
they are run generally by non-profit and
in a few cases for-profit providers and
that's a
they have something to lose we look at
districts that have the highest
percentage so while
2.5 million kids doesn't sound like a
lot when you look at the geographic
areas where they're concentrated so here
in california los angeles unified has
lost 200 000 kids to charter schools in
one district now when you have a million
kids that doesn't seem like a lot but
they've noticed
new orleans is the district in the
united states that now is at 90 percent
so again this is a little bit older data
because the study only comes out every
few months
almost 90 percent of kids in new orleans
go to charter schools there's no central
office
it's completely
open enrollment kids can go to any
school in the city and you have a lot of
competing providers
so what's happened in new orleans in
2005
62 percent of the schools were ranked as
failing by the state
in 2012 87 percent were ranked as
non-failing now that covers a lot of
gray area but it's been a huge change
and let's look at dig a little deeper
there's a lot of positive
research out of new orleans things are
going really well from graduation rates
to act scores to college attendance
but i think this is a compelling point
in 2005 new orleans was ranked 67th out
of 68th in the state
and since then they've moved up to the
middle to 38th ranking in the state
that's a huge leap for
a
city that had a hurricane that had their
infrastructure for their schools
completely wiped out and you know in
half a decade they've moved from the
very bottom to the middle of their state
in terms of outcomes so in this case
markets seem to be working
so
now
this gets kind of into the nitty-gritty
because public schools have noticed all
this competition
some of them have gotten into the act
and school financing in the united
states in general
the way states give districts money is
the money does follow the child to the
district
but after that everything breaks down
and it becomes a complete staffing model
and how much resources one school to
another gets is not at all dependent on
who enrolls there so the money does not
follow the child in the school district
everyone has average salaries so if you
have a very popular school in a high
income area they could have hundreds of
thousands of dollars more in salaries
because all of their staff based on
seniority rights
are
older and have been have more years of
experience and have higher salaries so
you think about like in la say or in san
diego because we're here in san diego
why is it that a school that draws down
all kinds of resources to the districts
could have so much less money because if
you have 100 hispanic kids that are all
on the free lunch program that are
disadvantaged you're drawing down all
kinds of money from the state and the
federal government to your district but
then at your school level you have high
turnover and you have all new teachers
that are at the lowest point in the
salary schedule
completely breaks down at the district
level all those kids generate the money
and then the money doesn't go to their
school and that's
how schools have been equitable so some
schools have districts in the united
states have moved to what's called the
weighted student formula where the money
follows the child
and
the child can enroll in any school in
the district and even within a public
system
it's more competitive than it used to be
and
these so we just did the study looking
at outcomes of these districts that have
moved to the school funding portability
where the money follows the child and
these are the districts in our study
which are places like baltimore and
prince george county in new york and
newark and then these are all the places
in the united states that are moving
towards this portable funding system and
it is because of competition from
charter schools and other markets
that they are trying to adopt more
public school choice policies in their
districts and they want more equity if
the money follows the child and we won't
debate whether that's a good thing or a
bad thing because i'm out of time and my
button's read so what we did is we i'm
in a cut to the chase we measured all
these different outcomes what's your
expected proficiency improvement given
your demographics are you closing
achievement gaps and we ranked all of
these districts houston gets an a plus
baltimore gets an f right so we had
about 20 different indicators and then
we looked at the amount of money in the
budget that's going to
the schools and you can see in
houston about 42 percent of all the
money goes to the school level the
principals make decisions it follows the
child in baltimore only 29 percent
houston is closing 22 achievement gaps
baltimore is closing two and then my
very last slide right here
what we find is that
the more money that follows the child
and the more that the principal makes
decisions and they know that if the
child leaves they'll lose the money and
the more purchasing power that kid has
on a number of indicators the better
they're doing so the green is how we
expected them to do giving their budget
the blue is how they're actually doing
and you can see there's variants some
schools are doing worse than they should
given their budget and some schools are
doing better but the bottom line is when
kids have purchasing power
and the money follows the child the
outcomes are improving more rapidly than
just giving money randomly to schools
and and that's what we found and that's
you know what we think is good and i'm
going to sit down now thank you all very
much
well thank you lisa um
terry moe is our next speaker and he's
the william
bennett
monroe professor of political science at
stanford university and he's also a
senior fellow at the hoover institute
he's written extensively on the politics
and reform of american education
his newest book special interests
teacher unions and america's public
schools
which i have brought with me to show you
provides the first comprehensive study
of this nation's teachers unions their
exercise of power and the collective
bargaining and politics and the vast
consequences these have for children
schools and reform
as a political scientist moe's research
extends well beyond education
he's written extensively on political
institutions public bureaucracy and the
presidency and his contributions to
these fields are widely cited
in addition to his positions at stanford
and hoover lois served as a senior
fellow at the brookings institution in
washington d.c please join me in
welcoming terry moore
thank you gary and
it's a pleasure to be here um
as you all know
this nation has been attempting to
reform its public schools for
over a quarter century
and here we are it's 2013
and our political leaders are still
saying
the system is broken
right we need to do something about this
why are they saying that
you know they're saying it because
this
long running
era of reform has basically been a
failure
so
why is that
well i think this is
really the question of our time
in understanding
how we can ever improve
america's schools we need to know what
the answer is so that we can do
something about it
and uh you know these things are
complicated politics is complicated
history is complicated
and we can make the answer as
complicated as we want
but i think the core
of an explanation is really simple
and it's rooted in a
universal that's true across all
institutions all institutions
generate vested interests
and so if you look at
doesn't matter what you look at health
care defense
agriculture social security right they
all generate
interest people and groups that have a
stake in those systems that benefit from
them as they are
and
will resist and mobilize power to resist
if reformers try to
change those systems in any fundamental
way
and the thing to recognize is just that
education is not special it's the same
it's the same as all these other
institutional systems this is a
universal thing
the only difference is that in education
the vested interests happen to be
unions the most powerful vested interest
well this is not true in the other areas
so you know when i point this out hey
you know the teachers unions are really
powerful they have a vested interest in
resisting change this is just an
objective phenomenon
you know people say well you just hate
unions
you know you're just a conservative
say no this is actually something that
happens everywhere in this country
across all policy realms and it happens
also in every other country of the world
and we shouldn't be surprised that it
happens in education
we need to recognize it
and understand it
all right so that's what my book is
about it's about
um the teachers unions
what their interests are their interests
are in jobs
you know this is not a horrible thing
it's a normal thing
right so teachers have a vested interest
in their jobs
reforms are threatening
to their jobs as they're rooted in the
existing system
and the teachers unions have taken
action very powerfully over the years to
protect those job interests of teachers
that's what this is all about
and i think that that goes a long way
toward explaining
a lot
of the failure not all of it but a lot
of it
that we've experienced over the last 30
years
and we need to understand that all right
so
my book is about union power how they've
exercised their power how successful
they've been in resisting reform
and today i'm just going to sort of hit
the highlights and talk in generalities
i'm not going to present a lot of facts
and figures but the facts and figures
are in this book
for better or worse it's 500 pages long
it has 90 pages of footnotes you know
people are always saying why didn't you
make it shorter you know why didn't you
make it like 10 pages you know is that
that kind of thing like a blog or
something right
but anyway if you're interested it's
there and today i'm just going to talk
in generalities
and you know i'll answer any questions
that you might have so let me start by
just pointing out that if we go back to
about 1960
teachers unions just weren't a factor
and
throughout the country
collective bargaining was mainly illegal
in government
but all that changed
beginning in 1960 basically and during
the 60s and 70s
states around the country outside the
south began adopting collective
bargaining laws for public sector
workers including teachers and the
result was an explosion of unionization
and collective bargaining all over the
country
and by the early 1980s in education the
result was that the teen teachers unions
were massively powerful with millions of
members lots of money and they became
the big power in public education and
the irony is that it was precisely at
that time that a nation at risk came out
warning of
um
a rising tide of mediocrity in america
schools and setting off the modern
reform mira but the modern reform mirror
took off at exactly the same time
that there was for the first time ever
this really powerful protector
of the existing system
and so throughout this period there has
been a powerful opponent of reform at
every step of the way
all right so how do the unions exercise
their power
they exercise it in two basic ways they
exercise it from the bottom up through
collective bargaining
and they exercise it from the top down
through politics so let me talk about
both
i think when when people think about
collective bargaining they think about
wages and benefits and that's really
what it's about
but a lot of collective bargaining is
about work rules
and you think about it you know
work rules
are easy for districts to give up
because they don't cost anything
right and so the unions have won a lot
of advantage in work rules over the
years and work rules are crucial because
what they are
are rules that shape
the organization of schooling they are
the organization of schooling
and what are work rules about jobs
they're shaped by the job interests of
unions and so what we get are big fat
contracts that are filled with rules
and these rules are from the standpoint
of effective organization perverse
and the reason is they weren't adopted
to make the organizations effective they
were adopted to protect jobs so for
instance um commonly there are seniority
rules
that allow senior teachers to transfer
to the jobs they want in the district
but what that really means is that the
district
can't put the right teacher in the right
school in the right classroom
district leaders lose that power they
can't allocate their most important
resource
in efficient ways
this is crucially debilitating
seniority based layoffs very common
right we're in a period of layoffs
but who gets laid off well junior people
automatically get laid off first well
some of these junior people may be the
very best teachers in their districts
doesn't matter they just lay them off
and then senior people are automatically
protected well some of those senior
people are terrible in the classroom and
everybody knows it yet they get kept on
what this is a formula for effective
organization i don't think so
but
everybody knows
that these are the rules and that
they're not adopted to make schools
effective
so i could go through a laundry list as
i do in the book
of all these rules right you have these
contracts that are 100 pages 150 pages
long to fill with rules
and the bottom line of it is
that
america's public schools are literally
not designed
to be effectively organized
they are organized in response to power
right so we shouldn't be surprised
that they're
pathological
right when it comes to the way they're
organized nobody designed them to be
effective
right so you might say well why didn't
the districts insist on this
well almost all districts are run by
school boards school board members are
elected
the most powerful force in those
elections
is the teachers unions
as a result in most districts if you
look at the school boards they consist
of people who are allies of the teachers
unions sympathizers people who support
collective bargaining and people who are
afraid right afraid that they're going
to lose their jobs if they do something
that unions don't like so it's rarely
the case that school boards will stand
up to the teachers unions in pushing for
more effective organization plus until
accountability came in the the districts
had no incentive to pursue effective
schools anyway
right it's just a bad scene
so where do you find districts actually
standing up to their unions
only really in districts where mayors
have taken control well there aren't
very many of those districts
but
the cases that you read about in the
paper of districts actually taking on
their unions new york city washington dc
chicago
those are districts where mayors are in
control they're district they're
different from school boards right
they're willing to do this sometimes
well how much progress have they made
not much
right
bloomberg here he's a multi-billionaire
a pretty powerful guy right
he's been trying for 12 years
to bring effective organization to the
new york city schools he's barely moved
the needle right they have more charter
schools fantastic right they've been
eliminate they've been able to eliminate
some seniority rules good
right they've been able to evaluate
teachers in some respects on the basis
of performance good
well
bloomberg's out
right
he's going to give way to de blasio
all right you know the last headline i
saw was he's considering appointing
randy weingarten as chancellor of the
schools you know
so
uh you know whether or not that happens
he hates charter schools
right he is an opponent of reform
so
the bottom line here is that mayors have
been up against real power in trying to
change the system and at best they've
achieved marginal
improvements you know good for them but
this is depressing
right this is not going to yield
a real transformation of the schools at
the local level the reality at the local
level is
ineffective organization
protected by power
right so now let's shift it up and talk
about
politics because the real reform process
really takes place
at the state level sometimes at the
national level through the political
process
the unions are
unbelievably powerful in politics
they
have
over 4 million members they have
enormous financial reserves
due to dues that come in every month
they are among the top contributors to
candidates and parties in most of the
states
they have small armies of campaign
workers in every political district all
over the country they have lobbying
organizations in every state they are
among
the most impressive political
organizations of any kind
in this country
and in education they just dwarf all the
other
political organizations
okay and they have the advantage of
working within a political system that's
filled with checks and balances
so
uh what you know much as we might like
madison right and admire the guy
the fact of the matter is that
any kind of reformist legislation is
very difficult to get through because it
has to make it over all these checks and
balances make it over all these veto
points
and if you want to block you just need
to be successful once
at one of these veto points so blocking
is much easier than getting anything
done
and that's all the unions want to do
they just want to block
and that's what they've been doing for
30 years
all right so quickly the two major
reform movements of our time are
accountability and school choice
you know we have a big monopolistic
system we spend 600 billion dollars a
year on it
and it's never been held accountable for
teaching kids anything
it only makes sense to have standards to
test kids and to have some consequences
when kids don't learn what they're
supposed to learn
but the unions are opposed to that they
do not want teachers to be evaluated
based on their performance and the last
thing they want is for any teachers to
lose a job so the teachers have been
opposed to this from the outset the
result is that we have very weak
accountability systems they lost in no
child left behind
but no child left behind has because of
the political blowback afterwards right
because the unions just kept after it
and clb has been eviscerated over the
years and so as of today it's still true
teachers are not held accountable
for teaching kids what they're supposed
to know
nobody ever loses a job because of poor
performance
and we've made very minimal progress 99
of teachers get satisfactory evaluations
it's a charade
all right so what about school choice
well with school choice makes perfect
sense you have a lot of kids in this
country who are stuck in terrible
schools
school choice gives them a way to get
out it's fantastic plus it provides the
regular public schools with some
competition you know if they didn't do a
good job they're going to lose kids and
lose money good
you know light a fire under them well
how do the unions approach this they
don't want kids to leave the regular
public schools that's where their
members are right if the kids leave
those schools then money and kids leave
but also jobs leave they don't want that
so they're opposed to school choice even
it's for the if it's for the poorest
kids in the country
and they've been very successful over
the years so lisa was talking about the
rise of school choice and you know i
think it's really exciting what's
happened over the years we do have some
school choice
but from my standpoint all it does is
demonstrate how powerful the unions are
you know the first charter school law
was passed in minnesota in 1991 over 20
years ago
and as of today five percent of the kids
are in charter schools is this a joke
five percent of the kids
the unions have been very successful at
keeping a lid on this thing over the
years
vouchers and
scholarships
260 000 kids
out of 50 million
this is nothing
and vouchers have been around longer
than charter schools
this is a real indication of what power
looks like
in suppressing these reforms
all right so uh how do things look going
forward um okay
under normal conditions the answer would
be bad
right and the reason it's bad is just a
very practical one they're powerful
right this is a this is a problem of
power
it's not about children
you know we like to think well you know
everybody wants good schools for kids
well even the unions want good schools
for kids but they have interests
at stake and the interests are what
they're pursuing
and power is what counts
okay so it
the only way to solve this is to reduce
their power
because their interests are not going to
change
right so we need somehow to reduce their
power the catch 22 is
they're powerful
and so if you try to take their power
away they will stop you now they didn't
stop scott walker
but the other 49 governors are looking
at scott walker and saying i'm not going
there
right because of what happened to him
right
so this is not going to like be some
sort of contagion what happened in
wisconsin
right that is not going to happen
um the most important thing that's
happening in the country on the
political side
is that there's a ferment within the
democratic party
there are liberals and moderates now who
were standing up and saying look this is
bad
um the unions are standing in the way of
reform they're preventing us from uh
doing what's right for poor kids we're
going to take some actions that the
unions don't like that's what obama and
duncan are doing that's why they did
race to the top good for them
you know as democrats that was a very
very unusual and courageous thing to do
and they did it
however they're a minority within the
democratic party and what this really
comes down to the real problem is that
the unions are the power center of the
democratic party
and so what the democrats have to do is
they have to say
yeah you know we think the unions are
not doing the right thing
in preventing reform
but we still support powerful unions
and they always will okay so the
democrats will not
address the power issue
this is not a solution
so are there any solutions
and i think the answer
unbelievably
is yes
after all this depression right
okay so yeah so uh here's the optimistic
part
what we need
basically
is to be hit by a meteor right to be hit
to have something from the outside
something from the outside if you rely
on stuff from the inside it's not going
to happen
right for power reasons
but if there's an exogenous
forest from the outside it can happen
okay
and
the answer ultimately is technology but
before i get there
think about new orleans why isn't why is
new orleans doing so great
because of katrina
right what katrina did
was not just destroy the school
buildings what katrina did was it
destroyed the union and it destroyed the
school district and as a result the
politicians in new orleans well mainly
at the state level
were free
the power structure was destroyed
this is the first time it's ever
happened in the history of this country
the power structure was destroyed in the
and the politicians were able to act
without constraint and what did they do
recreate the old system no way
they did something
totally innovative
and created the most different education
system in the whole country
why did it happen because of an
exogenous event
otherwise it would never have happened
in new orleans they'd still be terrible
to this day
okay so technology technology is this
massive revolution that is changing the
world it is going to transform education
online education is going to change
everything
um it is going to bring about a more
personalized approach to learning it's
not that every kid's going to be at home
in his bedroom you know
you know graduating from high school i
think they're going to be various forms
of blended learning taking place
we don't even know exactly how it's
going to happen but what's going to
happen throughout is what's happened
throughout history across industries
which is technology is going to be
substituted for labor
technology is cheap labor is very
expensive there just aren't going to be
as many teachers per student in the
future
it's going to get more and more that way
over time this is terrible for the
unions
right their membership is going to go
down their numbers are are going to go
down also teachers are no longer going
to be concentrated in districts
right because technology
uh does away with the need for
geographic concentration doesn't matter
where the students are where the
teachers are they could be anywhere in
the world this this is very bad you know
from the union standpoint also they're
going to be lots and lots of providers
out there and districts are increasingly
going to be contracting well the jobs
are going to go out the money's going to
go out
this is bad for the unions and so over
time what's going to happen i think
unions are resisting this they know this
they're not stupid right so they're
resisting this but this thing is huge
this is too big
and so if you play it out 10 20 30 years
the unions are going to go down as they
go down they're going to be less and
less capable of blocking
and all these kinds of reforms that have
been unable to pass
over the years are going to start going
through and we're increasingly going to
get
true reform
in american education is just going to
take a while
okay thank you
well with that ending i i can't resist
recommending hillsdale college's online
courses
which you can find by going straight to
uh the middle of our website um
richard vetter as our next speaker and
he he earned a degree in economics at
northwestern university's ba there and
his phd in economics is from the
university of illinois
he studies u.s economic history
particularly as it relates to public
policy
some of the specific research has
involved american immigration economic
issues in american education and the
inner relationship between labor and
capital markets
he's an adjunct scholar at the american
enterprise institute as the author of
numerous books and articles his
books include going broke by a degree
why colleges cost too much and i want to
put in a plug for that one that's that's
a really good one
and and his 2006 book the walmart
revolution he serves as the
distinguished professor of economics at
ohio university in athens ohio so please
help me in
introducing
professor vetter
thanks gary until the last three minutes
of terry's talk
i thought this was roughly the
intellectual equivalent of having a
hemorrhoid operation
from an unlicensed french physician back
from a wine laden lunch
let me present a counter factual
proposition
suppose the federal government had never
enacted the higher education act in 1965
or began providing financial assistance
to college students
in other words suppose we had no federal
guaranteed student loans
no pell grants no federal work study
programs no higher education tax credits
or other forms of federal financial
assistance
what would higher education be like
today
well no one knows for certain i expect
six things would have happened
first there would have been a somewhat
lower proportion of adult americans with
college degrees today
but absolutely and as a percent of the
adult population we would still be at an
all-time high
second
i suspect tuition fees of universities
would be significant lower
significantly lower my guess is that the
sticker prices at colleges or
universities would be conservatively 20
percent lower than they are now
maybe more
third
i would predict that the porsche the
proportion of recent college graduates
from the bottom quarter of the income
distribution would have been greater
than it actually is
higher education would be less
elitist
fourth
i would predict that the strong
disconnect between labor market
realities
and the outcomes of college graduates
would be significantly less
we would not have over a hundred and
fifteen thousand janitors or one million
retail sales clerks holding bachelor's
degrees or more
we have incidentally more janitors with
bachelor's degrees than chemists with
bachelor's degrees in this country
or architects
my statistic du jour
you will notice there are no power
points here i use west virginia
powerpoint i just
throw my hands
fifth
we would have had much better academic
performance than we have today we would
have fewer college dropouts and a larger
proportion of students graduating in
four years we would probably have less
grade inflation fewer climbing walls and
luxury dormitories
but a larger proportion of students
acquiring meaningful increments to their
knowledge
about our civilization and to their
critical thinking skills
six
we would have far fewer
collegiate bureaucrats
greater emphasis on teaching
and no million dollar university
presence
there will be no talk of a higher
education bubble or u s presidents
denouncing high university costs
the american council on education and
other groups would have fewer lobbyists
collecting economic rents from the
federal government in short
higher education would be a lot
different
now let me elaborate for a minute
i think federal provision of grants and
subsidized loans
has increased the demand
for education higher education it has
probably also increased the supply of
services too
but not as much
since many higher education institutions
do not try to maximize enrollments
indeed success in higher education is
often equated with refusing to accept
customers that's what terry schooled us
stanford
unique among businesses mcdonald's
doesn't have an admissions office but
stanford does
government programs have succeeded in
getting more kids through college
although i suspect the six-year
graduation rate of pell grant recipients
which is a state secret probably eluding
even the nsa
is somewhere in the order of one-third
for every pal recipient who graduates
two do not
since these financial aid programs raise
demand they lead to a higher tuition
fees
education secretary bill bennett
predicted that posited that idea
hypothesis in 1987
i think he was right then and right now
federal data suggests that around 1970
before pell grants even existed when
federal student loans were very modest
in number and size
about 12
5 10 12
percent of recent college graduates came
from the bottom quarter of the income
distribution
compared with
7
today
despite federal uh financial assistance
programs that have multiplied about
10-fold in inflation-adjusted terms
a smaller proportion of college
graduates or poor persons suggesting
these programs have abysmally failed at
achieving their goal of expanding
educational opportunities for the
economically less advantaged
lower income persons are more price
sensitive
than more affluent ones
so high sticker prices have led to
relatively more poorer persons saying no
to college
or picking less expensive options like
community colleges the fafsa forum
required by the federal government has
been historically a highly complicated
intrusive way of getting financial ins
information by the way the only college
in the united states that doesn't allow
any of this thing to happen is hillsdale
i might add
kids from affluent families complained
but completed this form but many lower
income families just gave up rather than
answer over 100 questions
many demanding highly personal
information that asks if asked by any
other business might lead to criminal
prosecution of the business
go into a car dealer and they say fill
out a form tell us what your net worth
is and then we'll tell you the price of
the car
in 1970 less than one percent of taxi
drivers had college degrees by 10
2010
the proportion exceeded 15
college graduates since their degrees
means a ticket to a moderately affluent
middle class life
in managerial technical or professional
jobs
yet almost half of the graduates
are in of all all college graduates are
in occupations that the department of
labor tells us typically requires less
than a college education
the modern day enrollment
explosion fueled by student financial
aid programs has aggravated enormously
this problem
the connection between academic
performance and federal financial aid is
also real maybe less obvious but real
the time students spend on academics has
declined in tandem with increased
federal student aid programs grades have
risen but student academic effort has
fallen with increased student aid
the civics literacy test of the
intercollegiate studies institute or the
decennial adult literacy survey the u.s
department of education show that core
knowledge and literacy amongst college
students are falling
a room in rokska compellingly argued
that critical thinking and writing
skills are not substantially advanced
during the college years
despite rampant grade inflation college
dropout rates remain stubbornly high
six-year graduation rate is officially
reported nationally to be about 60
percent 40 percent don't graduate
i think one reason for deteriorating
academic standards is that there are no
performance expectations associated with
federal student financial aid
colleges have no skin in the game so
they promote federal student borrowing
for those who they know
have a low probability of academic
success
all of this contributes to a dumbing
down of curriculum and standards by the
way i'm in my 49th year of teaching
and i taught yesterday
by tv
technology
as terry's right by the way
i'm coming to it we're going to pick up
common theme here actually
as colleges have raised tuition fees
more because of students uh
of federal student aid this has
increased their revenues where are these
funds gone
looking at changes in college staffing
and spending suggests that a large
portion has gone for non-instructional
purposes such as huge growth in the
number of administrators rising
university revenues have probably also
stimulated the college ediphys complex
expensive buildings many for
non-academic purposes the federal
student financial aids are helping fund
a costly and academically dubious
academic arms race
now i have emphasized that the current
federal financial aid program is
dysfunctional
costly not achieving its egalitarian
goals increasing tuition fees and so
forth
getting rid of it is highly desirable
ideally i think it should be eliminated
not reformed the dilemma however is that
an immediate elimination of the program
would be disruptive and arguably unfair
to individuals using these programs in
short there are significant transitional
issues involved in abandoning the status
quo moreover given the huge political
constituency going back to power again
receiving or anticipating federal
student financial aid it is probably
politically impossible to eliminate
these programs overnight but i think
there may be
possibly a politically feasible way to
mitigate the negative impacts
here are seven
ways to dramatically
reduce the taxpayer burden and the
inefficiencies and pathologies
associated with the current system
first restore the original goal of
helping poor persons attend college
right now over 17 percent of students
from families
with incomes from 60 to 80 000
a year
get pell grants
these are families
with above median incomes and they get
pell grants
we should greatly
tighten eligibility reduce the number of
pell grant recipients by maybe 50
percent
similarly plus loans to parents of high
income kids should end tuition tax
credits benefit mostly affluent families
whose kids would go to college even
without them
go to a single grant program in a single
loan program
second impose academic performance
standards to continue receiving grants
rewards students who graduate in less
than four years and eliminate aid for
say students in their sixth year of
full-time attendance you can go six
seven years and get a pell grant
third have federal governments stop
making loans rather merely guaranteeing
loans made by private lenders the feds
have to borrow to pay their own bills so
implicitly they borrow from say chinese
bond purchasers in order to make college
loans
not only
return lending to private lenders but
strengthen the tie between interest
rates charged to students and market
rates
fourth
make participating colleges have skin in
the game
if colleges accept students and promise
them pell grants or guaranteed loans
make them share the burden associated
with high levels of loan defaults and
low graduation rates this should reduce
the number of students lacking the
aptitude the background or discipline
for college learning
i'm not part of the college for all
crowd you can see
fifth
limit federal aid to assisting students
attain just a basic college education
from a relatively low-cost university
limited assistance to a few thousand
dollars a year and do not subsidize a
harvard education more than one at a
relatively lower-cost university right
now there's a vicious circle colleges
raise their tuition fees so the feds
make larger loans to students leading
the colleges to raise their tuition fees
again
capps student federal assistance
increases to the inflation rate
six convert pell grants into educational
vouchers going back to lisa's earlier
point
now pal money is distributed through
school financial aid offices colleges
offer government money to students as if
it were their own money why not give the
money to the student directly and let
them use it wherever they want
empowering them more and making
institutions more attentive to student
needs moreover such educational vouchers
could go only to low-income students if
you wanted similarly the vouchers
amounts could be tied to good academic
progress
top students could be paid a little
extra for superior academic performance
if we made five million of these grants
at an average amount of four thousand
dollars a piece the cost would be twenty
billion a year which is forty percent
less than we spent uh currently on pell
grants and all americans attending
college who were truly poor
would be accommodated
seventh encourage private investors to
begin human capital equity funds
where students sell equity in themselves
rather than debt
the investor would pay college costs up
front with a graduate paying the
investor a porsche a proportion of the
income for a specified time periods
markets would adjust in favor of
students with better graduation in
vocational prospects a graduate from mit
majoring in electrical engineering might
pay eight percent of his income for 15
years
well one majoring in anthropology from
central michigan university
i might pay
72 percent of their income for 50 years
these market signals would help
reallocate resources within higher
education
summarizing i think the federal
government should exit
providing financial assistance americans
have suffered from the byzantine system
a federal loan
grant work studying tax plan credit
plans but if government financing is
going to continue at least rationalize
it
downsize it and redirect it
now let's talk for the
turn by the way i am the only one who's
going to finish on time
that's the difference between economist
political scientists and think tank
let's let's turn to the future
massive government interference in
education markets have dulled and
reduced healthy market signals needed to
reallocate education resources but
markets are powerful and market signals
are working albeit slower than in an
unsubsidized unregulated environment
enrollments are currently declining at
american colleges and universities
mediocre college quality public
universities and private liberal arts
colleges with little national reputation
or few distinctive qualities are
particularly vulnerable real tuition
increases are lessening and some schools
out of desperation are actually cutting
fees
state government subsidies will rise
only modestly as higher education is
being crowded out by other entitlement
spending especially for medical care at
the federal
level a high debt to output ratio
impedes expanded higher education
financing as america embraces the
welfare state with obamacare and other
program expansions
the nation's overall rate of economic
growth is dropping abruptly and sharply
reducing the capacity of private
philanthropy to fund higher education
revenue growth possibilities and higher
education are limited
there's also a fundamental demand side
problem the gap between student
expectations
and labor market reality has grown
greatly from 2006 to 2012 the college
high school earnings differential for
for full-time students actually fell
while college costs rose considerably
this is unsustainable we're in the era
of the college educated taxi driver
janitor and bartender more persons are
quite rationally saying no to college
schumpeterian creative destruction is
coming to higher education
several hundred existing institutions
will disappear
colleges resist change but nonetheless
it will come part of it will come by
substituting electronic forms of
instruction for existing instructional
methods that date back to socrates
part will come by traditional
residential higher education undergoing
major changes perhaps reversing rapid
increases in non-instructional staff and
reduced teaching loads supporting
increasingly trivial research endeavors
articles in the journal of last resort
and so on
since 1985 there have been 35 000
articles written on william shakespeare
three a day
he died in 1615.
tenure will go
non-degree forms of demonstrating
competency to employers might emerge
perhaps by creating a test of critical
thinking skills and core knowledge call
it the college equivalency test model on
the ged test for high school
diploma equivalency who knows
maybe we'll
emulate oxford in continental european
schools with three-year bachelor's
degrees
well the specifics that i've given here
here may be wrong
large changes are ahead for american
higher education and i conclude with 25
seconds left on my time
what a terrific panel that was uh maybe
you can give everybody
okay with that we have a few minutes for
questions and if you raise your hand i
will call on you but please wait because
this is being recorded until you get a
microphone and so the first question
will be right there
and the panelists will remain seated
my question is for mr mo
while no fan of teacher unions i would
argue that the real problem in american
k-12 education is a uncompetitive
education system lacking in the free
market discipline
unions
compete at ups against ununionized fedex
in a relatively free market system
successfully
but
in education
because the lack of market discipline
they control the system your comments
well i think unions thrive in a
non-competitive environment
right that's exactly what they want
um
and uh
i i think that it is true that that
competition
imposes discipline
on them
but
you take a look at the private sector
only seven percent of workers are
unionized now why is that
right i think a lot of that is due to
the fact that with globalization and the
increasingly competitive nature of the
u.s economy
unions have increasingly been driven out
right because i think what unions do is
they impose higher costs on firms and
they impose more rigid organizational
structures that make effective and
efficient performance difficult and so
well i think it is possible uh for some
unions in some kind companies uh to
function well and not drive their
companies out of business
and put them at a competitive
disadvantage
uh i think that's typically not what
happens right what happens is that they
do put their companies at a disadvantage
right and so that's why i think
in the public sector as well as in the
private sector unions fight against
competition what unions want
is a regulated safe monopolistic
environment that's what they thrive
okay um yes right there
thank you all for an excellent
presentation this is for the whole panel
i would like one of you or all of you to
comment on what you do with the united
states department of education thank you
start on this thing
lisa okay
i mean
the u.s department of education i guess
is just a reflection of
the entire problem
and the politics
you know the political aspect of
education and so
problem is is that the vested interests
rely on the money now from the u.s
department of education so
on the one hand there may be you may be
able to reach people within the federal
government
in terms of congressional leaders or
whatever that want to reduce the
department of education but the
stakeholders that lobby
for the money and the increasing amounts
of money i mean it's the same problem
that we have with getting rid of pell
grants we're getting rid of
unions the political interests are all
supporting keeping the u.s department of
education intact and as much as they
might complain about them encroaching on
their rights and their roles
even with you know states
that have made a stand against the
federal government and said no we're not
taking the money when you check back a
few months later in fact they have taken
the money so there's not a lot of
examples of even with federalism of
states taking an actual stand in the end
where they say we won't take the money
and we won't be regulated but i think
federalism is ultimately the only way
that that will happen if you actually
have someone in texas opting out
completely of the system and not taking
federal dollars
in the end that could reduce the
department of education but i'm not
optimistic about that happening anytime
soon
now let me just add something to that i
don't know if this will be very popular
in this group but i'm going to like put
it out there
um
look
i faced this a lot at hoover you know i
think there there's a lot of
wistful thinking about bringing
democracy back to the people and local
governance and
bringing and getting the national
government out of this and governance by
the states and everything
and i have to remember that the whole
reason this country started reforming
the schools back in the 1980s is that
the states did a terrible job
of running their school systems
how about the local systems they're
terrible you know not all of them but a
lot of them i mean you know palo alto
has a very nice school system right
detroit doesn't
okay so it's not like we can return
governance to the local level and
decentralize and everything is going to
be great it won't be and a big push for
federal involvement of some kind came
about because of failures that are very
real
at the local level where actually the
vested interests are much more powerful
so i'm i'm actually not a big fan for
the national government just getting out
of this also you know in terms of fiscal
equivalence
it turns out that you know education is
a national problem that has huge
implications for our whole economy right
for our well-being as a society
this is not an issue that the national
government should just punt on
right it needs to play some kind of a
role now i i think the solution and the
final analysis
ideally would be a full-blown choice
system
right where we can have
autonomous schools making their own
decisions about hiring and firing and
allocating budgets and all the rest and
without constraints by unions and so on
but they would have to make it within
some sort of overarching framework
right that that guarantees equal access
and and things like that and so the
question is how do we strike that
balance but you know these knee-jerk
solutions of getting the federal
government out i i think are just wrong
in higher education it's a somewhat
different situation because we have
historically we've had state-run
universities and colleges with the
federal government playing an extremely
small role
the federal government has tried to play
a little bit of a bully
pulpit role and i guess i'm echoing
terry in one respect here that in some
ways has been a little bit positive in
the last few years there was a
commission which i happened to serve on
called the spellings commission six or
seven years ago at least
it made some some modestly positive
recommendations that if adopted would
have you know increasing accountability
more
information systems this sort of thing
which the things we need uh had done
some good things so there's been some
good things happen on the whole however
the whole system has been
worsened i think because federal
involvement partly because of the
financial things that i was talking
about here
and uh
i think the strength in higher education
of the american system relative to
european system is precisely the kind of
thing that was talked about here we do
have more choice in higher ed than we do
in public education we have several
thousand universities this is the one
area where we have some choice it's also
one area where the customer has a little
skin in the game they pay some money
which i think has been good uh
they actually have to you know some
responsible financial responsibilities
so i think higher ed is somewhat
different that way and i would hate to
see the federal government try to
homogenize it which i fear is is is is
happening to some extent it's a
complicated thing i can't take longer
than that i mean the accreditation we
should take the creditors out and shoot
them for example uh
uh
but we don't have time to talk about
that
all right uh right here in the
front wait for the mic please
one thing i haven't heard here today
is how does the in a disciplined
human work ethic
relate to this educational problem
somebody say something
this is the basis of our culture
let me
picking up on the gentleman's question
by me
in the year 2000 64 out of every 100
americans over the age of 16
worked
worked
now less than 58 do
we we would have 12 14 million more
people in the labor force if we worked
at the same level we did just 15 years
ago
and a lot of it i believe is related to
a variety of federal innova
interventions and some of which are in
education and some of which are in other
areas such as welfare policies and so
forth charles murray
has spoken eloquently on this in the
past so we do have a problem
and i'm not sure that the level of
literacy among the general public has
been enhanced through increasing
educational attainment over time in
dealing with this i do think we have
have some problems
his discipline in terms of
student behavior to a certain extent
so the work ethic
so i mean i think
that's one of the things
one of the things with the traditional
education system
being so
restrictive
and the same especially for secondary
school for middle school and high school
is
that it has reduced i think the number
of kids that are in the labor force
because in some ways the college for all
mentality which you know there are some
things about that that is good in the
sense that you want kids
learning at a level where they could go
to college so you don't necessarily want
them to go to college but you do want
them to have
learning expectations that if they
wanted to go to college they would know
enough to go considering that we've
spent
sixty thousand dollars on each of them
they should be able to go to cal state
fullerton if they chose but
because we have been so focused on that
i think you know like my son is in um
industrial arts program where they you
know build cars and solar boats and
he's been doing welding and metal shop
and all these things and he loves it and
in our district
it's we have 60 000 kids and there's
enough slots for maybe 300 kids to do
that you know like if kids were
interested in that there's just very few
opportunities and we've moved away from
expanding options in some ways and
that's the good thing about the school
choice movement is that there are niche
schools that have tried to go back to
choices that would lead to more work for
kids but you know we've focused away
from work
and toward seat based time for all kids
and i think that that has been because
of the work rules that have reduced
choice and innovation
okay um i'd like to take one for
actually standing in the very back there
which make jenna run around
so this is for anyone in the panel if my
supposition holds water it probably
affects all of you but lisa was from
your slide the first
graphic that you put up showed
1970 as a comparison point
and i think you could make an argument
that if 1970 education was good
those people that were educated in that
system
implemented everything that we're
finding flaws with now
could you would you make that point um
so you may be comparing something that's
bad against something that maybe was bad
so i mean 1970 largely is a data point
because
both it's when many things changed in
terms of the way
unions and collective bargaining happen
but also it's just an artifact right of
the data collection systems that we have
in that we became more focused on
testing and national data at that point
but you know i would argue that
the measurement at that time was not
good in terms of graduation rates and
student performance and when you look at
outliers like
sorry the state of massachusetts which
have made gains for 17 year olds or
other countries when you benchmark the
national test against international
tests
it's clear that the whole world has not
plateaued everywhere and that no one
that in 1970 we were at the peak of
educational attainment and we can only
go down from there that is clearly not
what the case is
so i do think that we've increased
inflationary spending on both higher and
public k-12 education
and the fact that across multiple
variables we've really seen no change or
improvement and we have other places or
outliers that have seen change and
improvement
that it just goes to
you know
and the other question is if nothing has
changed why don't we still spend fifty
thousand dollars i mean if we're if
everything's exactly the same and the
outcomes are the same
in inflation adjusted dollars why would
our costs go up so much we should just
do everything exactly the same because
it was perfect and we would only spend
fifty thousand dollars and we'd all be
good
i'll just add a few a few points uh
you know i think performance
we don't have really good measures from
the early days but i think performance
was better back then than it is now
and
major things though have also changed
um one of the things that's changed is
unions as i've talked about and i think
unions have had a huge impact on
uh
the nature of the school system you know
the way it's organized i think it's
they're just many more constraints and
restrictions
uh imposed
on districts they know they already had
it bad i mean they you know their
incentives were all wrong and you know
they were monopolistic and they already
had all sorts of reasons for performing
badly and then they got unionized you
know made things much worse but uh but
another thing that happened and this is
obvious and you all probably know this
but
women
used to have no options in this country
and they became teachers or nurses
and so the very best women in this
country the best brains
who happen to be women became teachers
and so we had this spectacular work
force back then
and
the women's revolution freed women to
become lawyers and doctors and
professors and all the rest and they did
right so now half the medical school
classes are women half the law school
classes are women this is a true
revolution but i think it's really had
an impact on the quality of the teaching
force
okay so that that's a major thing
uh another major thing is that the
demographics of the school population
have changed dramatically and so it's
really important in assessing
performance changes over time to
separate out these groups and take a
look at performance changes across
groups
it's a bad
a bad situation even if you look at just
white students
but it's not as bad as when you just
pool all these students together because
you would expect performance to to take
a hit just because the demographic
changes
well the red button has come on so we
have time for one more question and i'd
like to um let's say in the back there
right yes jenna yes yes you go yes
hi um no one's really touched on
parental involvement
i my daughters went to an elementary
school here in san diego with about 350
children
and i was on the governor's committee
which
took money from the state and decided
how to allocate it we had
less than 50 children in the school that
scored below
school
below the california guidelines
so we took that money those thousands of
dollars and put them into those kids and
over three years it didn't change at all
and my feeling was and as was some of
the other parents is that that money
that was funneled into those 50 kids
and taken away from the other 300 kids
went to children that didn't have
parents that were really involved there
was a language barrier in a lot of the
homes
and there just wasn't the um i don't
know appreciation or responsibility so
in everything that we've been talking
about you know we've i feel like
parents have kind of shifted the
responsibility onto the teachers and
under the schools
and when are the parents going to start
taking the responsibility back also
so
with parent i mean you're right
obviously like when the coleman report
in 1966 i mean parents and home
environment is a difficult challenge and
always will be
so then it
comes what are the best kinds of
institutional structures
that
will work
to mitigate things that happen to kids
at home so clearly
the more centralized monopolistic union
controlled structures
don't
they alienate parents even more so the
kind of school that you're describing
even though your investment in the end
didn't pay off the fact even that you
could
analyze as a parent how those resources
were being spent and how those decisions
were being made is still an improvement
over because you at least knew
right that your investment wasn't paying
off and then you can try to make other
decisions moving forward which in most
schools in america there's nobody
looking at did we make this extra
investment in these 50 kids and did what
we were doing help no one's asking that
question at all so i think the
autonomous schools that terry talks
about without
where they have a performance framework
where there's expectations
where parent where the people truly
closest to the kids the parents parent
committees the principals the teachers
that they're not always going to have
the right incentives but they have
better incentives than institutions that
are really far removed from making
decisions about what happens in the
school so in our large study i mean it
really showed that
the districts that removed work rules
that had collective bargaining relief
that gave principals a lot of the money
that use school site councils that in
general though on a variety of
indicators those districts are making
progress in comparison to other
districts so i think you know a
structure that even within a fake market
in the public system not the true market
that we would want is still better than
the most centralized system that we have
most places
all right i'll i'll say something uh
here at the end um look as a political
scientist
you know one of the things that stands
out in our field is that
long ago
you know in the 40s and 50s
uh political scientists used to
frequently say things like you know if
voters could just be more involved
if they would just
you know vote for really qualified
candidates and you know forget about
party and forget about ideology and we
need really high turn all this stuff
right
well okay
um the fact is
as as robert dahl one of the most famous
of all political scientists said
politics for most people is just a
sideshow in the great circus of life
right and what he meant by that is they
don't want to do those things right
they don't they don't think about
politics all the time they don't really
want to vote they don't you know there
are some people who do but a lot of
people don't and if your whole approach
to reform and to politics
is to think that you can get
masses of ordinary people really
involved in politics
you're going to be disappointed all the
time almost right so what you have to do
is recognize that this is sort of
a given
except in special circumstances that
most people most of the time just don't
want to do this and this is especially
true when you have like very poor and
disadvantaged populations
they have very difficult lives they're
working all the time they're juggling
all sorts of things and they are not
going to participate most of the time
very actively in schools so it would be
much better if they did
and we need to try things to get them
involved but to think that this is the
solution
is is wrong because it's going to turn
into a disappointment and so the second
best solution i think is choice
and autonomy at the school level
because that gives parents a buy-in
right there's a personal connection
between the people at the schools and
those parents and it maximizes the
opportunities for those parents to
participate to feel comfortable
participating and a larger percentage of
those parents will participate but
there's always going to be a big gap
between the ideal and reality
don't you get some west virginia wisdom
for us here
very quickly anita is having a fit over
here she's wanting to get us off the
stage uh
i
my last words would be
we are often said to have the best
higher education system in the world i
don't know if we do but we thought to be
pretty good in that area we're often
considered to have a mediocre k-12
system what is the biggest
distinguishing characteristics between
the two the two is
higher education has vastly more choice
than k through 12 and higher ed
the customer has skin in the game not
true in k through 12. they have skin in
the game in that they love their
children
but they they don't have skin in the
game in the sense that they have a
financial involvement which is often
very a powerful incentive
uh to inform human behavior
all right this uh
hour and a half flew by so
thank you to our panelists